Traduttore: Monica Prox
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Sono le 5:30 del mattino.
Londra, 12 agosto 2012.
Spengo la sveglia, anche se quella notte,
in realtà, non ho dormito parecchio,
perché fra un'ora c'è un pullman
che mi porterà a giocare la partita
più importante della mia carriera.
La partita che vale una medaglia olimpica.
Ora, serve una premessa.
Come avete intuito
quando sono entrato sul palco
io non sono stato un grande atleta
che è diventato allenatore di pallavolo,
che è un po' lo stereotipo classico
del mondo dello sport.
Mi piacerebbe raccontarvi,
come fa qualche mio collega,
che ero molto bravo,
avevo talento,
poi mi sono fatto male
e ho dovuto iniziare ad allenare.
No; ero sano come un pesce.
Semplicemente non avevo talento
a sufficienza per diventare un atleta,
cosa che mi sarebbe piaciuta moltissimo.
Matteo vi ha raccontato del mio giro,
che è stato un po' lungo.
Ho incominciato ad allenare
in questa città, che è la mia città,
in un oratorio di questa città,
di un borgo, si chiama Borgo San Paolo.
Ho incominciato da lì un percorso
che è passato attraverso
cinque campionati diversi,
dieci città diverse,
tre nazioni: l'Italia,
la Grecia e la Finlandia,
che sono parti del mondo che
mi hanno fatto diventare quel che sono.
Pensavo un po' a queste cose
quella mattina alle 5:30,
sapendo che quel pullman
sarebbe partito un'ora dopo
per portarmi all'Hell's Court,
il posto, il luogo dove la nostra squadra
avrebbe giocato quella partita.
L'Hell's Court è una
di quelle architetture resistenti
che sono state capaci di cambiare
nel corso della storia
la loro destinazione d'uso.
Alla fine dell'800 c'era la sede europea
del "Buffalo Bill's Wild West Show",
pensate quanti sogni
sono transitati di lì.
Poi, all'interno di quella struttura,
pensata per i grandi eventi musicali,
nel 1973 David Bowie fece un concerto
che siglò il record storico
di persone che erano andate
ad assistere a un concerto rock indoor.
Nel 1992 un nuovo edificio,
tanto per essere coerente
con questo luogo di produzione di sogni,
venne inaugurato
da una principessa, Lady Diana.
Poi in occasione della trentesima edizione
dei giochi olimpici, Londra 2012,
quel posto era stato scelto
per disputare le partite di pallavolo.
Quello era, in quel giorno,
il teatro dei miei sogni.
Purtroppo era lontanissimo
da dove stavamo noi,
era a più di un'ora di tragitto
in condizioni normali,
però quel giorno, tanto per complicare
le cose, c'erano due fatti:
il primo: era l'ultimo giorno dei giochi,
il giorno in cui si corre la maratona.
La maratona arrivava nel centro di Londra,
che quindi era completamente paralizzato.
Il secondo fatto era che la nostra partita
aveva un orario d'inizio particolare:
le 8:30 del mattino.
La pallavolo è uno sport
di forza esplosiva
non è un capriccio, non è questione
di allenamento o di abitudine.
È molto difficile essere performanti
a quell'ora del mattino,
è un fatto biologico.
Nessuno dei miei atleti aveva mai giocato
una partita che incominciasse a quell'ora.
Era tutto completamente nuovo,
era una situazione, una sensazione
completamente sconosciuta.
Era tutto meravigliosamente inallenabile.
Nessuno dei nostri protocolli,
tutte quelle cose che nello sport
si fanno con grande precisione
e con grande attenzione ai dettagli,
sembrava essere utile
quel giorno; nessuna.
Forse una sì,
perché su quel pullman,
che mi avrebbe portato
al teatro dei miei sogni,
io incominciavo a realizzare
che quello che mi stava capitando -
lì, seduto, con il mio sacchettino
con la colazione dentro,
un panino e un succo di frutta,
così come si fa nelle gite scolastiche -
quella sensazione era molto vicina
a quello che avevo fatto 25 anni prima
quando in questa città allenavo
i ragazzini dell'oratorio.
Dovevo calcolare bene
i tempi degli spostamenti,
trovare la pizzeria giusta
per arrivare a mangiare,
insomma in modo che fosse né troppo presto
né troppo tardi, rispetto alla partita.
Paradossalmente,
era tutto diverso da ciò che avevo fatto
negli ultimi anni della mia carriera
in serie A, agli Europei, ai Mondiali,
nelle World League.
E altrettanto paradossalmente,
quel giro lungo, iniziato dall'oratorio,
mi stava riportando al suo inizio.
Grazie alla solerzia
degli organizzatori locali
arrivammo al campo di gioco
con un anticipo pazzesco.
Chiudete un attimo gli occhi,
immaginate di essere un atleta
che deve andare in campo
a giocare per una medaglia olimpica.
Provate a pensarvi a guardare
il soffitto dello spogliatoio
dovendo aspettare più di un'ora
l'inizio della gara.
Riuscite ad immaginare
la tensione, il nervosismo,
quell'energia nervosa che si brucia
e che, però, sapete che presto
vi servirà dannatamente.
La mia fortuna fu quella di percepire
quello stato d'animo collettivo.
Chiamai la squadra intorno a me
e feci un discorso di poche parole.
Dissi: "Voglio raccontarvi la storia di
un saltatore in alto, un atleta come voi
che ha avuto lo stesso sogno vostro,
per tutta la sua vita, fin da bambino:
vincere una medaglia olimpica.
Immaginate che quell'atleta abbia,
insieme al suo staff di allenatori,
studiato in maniera meticolosa
le condizioni in cui dovrà competere
il 12 agosto del 2012, a Londra.
Sa ed è consapevole che il 12 agosto
a Londra normalmente ci sono 24 gradi,
c'è il 70% di tasso d'umidità,
c'è una leggera brezza di 4/5 nodi
che soffia da sud-est a favore di rincorsa
e ha ricreato quelle condizioni
e si è allenato in quelle condizioni
ogni singolo giorno
degli ultimi quattro anni.
È perfetto, si sente pronto,
si sente imbattibile.
Poi arriva il 12 agosto 2012.
E quando quell'atleta entra nella pista
di atletica dello stadio olimpico
succede che piove.
Piove, fa freddo, la pedana
è scivolosa, c'è un vento forte.
Quali sono le due scelte?
La medaglia verrà
comunque assegnata quel giorno,
la vincerà chi sarà più agile.
E questo concetto di agilità ha a che fare
con la fisicità, che serve agli sportivi,
però è un concetto
anche molto intellettuale.
È una sorta di leggerezza,
di capacità di muoversi in modo efficace
di interpretare qualche dettaglio
e di rimettere insieme dei pezzi
che sembrano scomporsi tra le tue mani.
Io dissi:
"Sono certo che siate consapevoli che
tutto quello che avete fatto fino ad oggi
è stato importante,
perché se voi non aveste avuto
quell'attenzione ai dettagli,
quella cura del particolare,
quella ricerca del protocollo,
oggi voi non sareste seduti
in questo spogliatoio,
ci sarebbe qualcun altro al posto vostro.
Però, oggi, voi dovete sbarazzarvi
di quello che vi siete portati fino a qui.
Dovete togliervi questo zaino
che è troppo pesante e che oggi
non servirà, anzi, sarà di ostacolo.
Chiusi questo piccolo discorso
dicendo una cosa molto semplice
che però sentivo davvero in quel momento
e dissi semplicemente:
"Voglio che sappiate che sono
dannatamente orgoglioso di essere qui
con ciascuno di voi,
oggi, sotto questa pioggia.
Cacciai letteralmente gli atleti
dallo spogliatoio,
chiesi loro di andare
a fare colazione, fuori.
Immaginatevi la scena
con gli addetti alla sicurezza
che rincorrevano gli atleti
che andavano a prendere un caffè.
Ci demmo appuntamento
mezz'ora dopo, nello stesso spogliatoio,
dove io non parlai quasi più.
Feci solo un gesto.
Appesi in quello spogliatoio
una maglia azzurra,
la maglia numero 16
di Vigor Bovolenta,
un atleta che aveva vestito quella maglia
197 volte fino alle olimpiadi di Pechino
e che cinque mesi prima di quella partita
era tragicamente scomparso
per un problema cardiaco,
giocando a pallavolo.
Appesi quella maglia insieme alle altre
e dissi semplicemente -
ricordai semplicemente l'importanza
di non lasciarsi cose non dette, non fatte
dicendo che in qualche modo,
in qualche forma, quel giorno,
avremmo potuto contare
su un giocatore in più.
Non avrei certo immaginato
che quattro anni dopo
sarei stato chiamato a raccontare
di queste vicende a un TED.
Però credo, in quel momento,
di aver pensato esattamente:
"This must be the place",
questo dev'essere il posto,
dev'essere il posto dove io, dove noi
realizzeremo i nostri sogni
anche se completamente diverso
da quello che ci saremmo aspettati.
Sta a noi renderlo tale, oggi.
Mi venne in mente il luogo
da dove i nostri sogni erano iniziati:
il Foro Italico,
lo Stadio dei Marmi, a Roma,
da lì la delegazione olimpica
si muove simbolicamente
per andare a ricevere la bandiera olimpica
dal presidente della Repubblica.
Pensai a quel luogo
con un riferimento alla leggerezza,
proprio quella di Italo Calvino,
nelle "Lezioni americane"
perché anche il Foro Italico è un luogo
che ha saputo trasformare clamorosamente
la destinazione
per la quale era stato pensato.
Perché quel luogo era stato pensato
per celebrare la pesantezza
e l'orrore dell'apologia fascista.
Era stato pensato per dividere il mondo
ed era stato capace di trasformarsi,
ospitando nel 1960
l'edizione forse più bella
dei giochi olimpici, quella di Roma,
quella di Abebe Bikila,
della sua corsa leggera a piedi scalzi,
la maratona vinta
sotto l'arco di Costantino,
i giochi di Cassius Cley,
i giochi di Nino Benvenuti,
i giochi di Wilma Rudolph,
i giochi di un ragazzo torinese che
Wilma Rudolph guardava con tenerezza,
si chiamava Livio Berruti
e vinse i 200 metri
con un'immagine meravigliosamente
romantica, quella di un volo di colombe
che accompagnavano la sua curva
prima della dirittura d'arrivo,
che sottolineavano quella leggerezza,
che aveva trasformato anche quel luogo
nato per un obiettivo completamente
diverso, nato per dividere il mondo,
in un luogo dove il mondo, quel giorno,
trovava la sua sintesi più bella.
[Musica di sottofondo]
Non ricordo quasi nulla della partita
che ci ha assegnato la medaglia.
Ricordo la tensione,
le difficoltà da superare,
il senso di far parte
di qualcosa di grande,
ricordo che ci fu, però, con chiarezza
in tutti noi una sensazione,
non pensammo mai, neanche per un istante,
che non avremmo vinto quella partita.
Ripensai tante volte
a quello che era successo,
ricordo l'ultimo punto, quello che segnò
la fine di quel percorso
e ricordo che dopo quell'ultimo punto,
sul podio olimpico,
ricomparve quella maglia
che avevamo appeso negli spogliatoi
con un gesto di una bellezza straordinaria
che fece il giro del mondo
e che è ancora la mia medaglia,
perché, non so se sapete,
con grande crudeltà ai giochi olimpici
la medaglia agli allenatori non la danno.
La medaglia... va solo agli atleti.
[Applausi]
Poco dopo -
Poco dopo ripensai a Calvino,
guardando ai miei atleti sul podio.
Una sensazione che
vi raccontano tanti atleti,
una specie di passaggio schizofrenico
fra la gioia assoluta e la melanconia
sono sorrisi che si spengono,
occhi che si abbassano.
Come diceva Calvino, la melanconia
è tristezza che diventa leggera.
Come se lì, sul podio,
tu scoprissi che il viaggio
che ti ha portato fino a lì è finito
e quell'isola di utopia
che hai ricercato per tanti anni
si dissolve sotto tuoi piedi appena
tu ci hai messo il primo passo sopra.
Ricordo anche la sera
dopo quella medaglia,
passeggiavo nel villaggio olimpico,
l'ultimo giorno dei giochi,
ripetendomi in maniera ossessiva
che quel sogno che io avevo da bambino,
che era stato possibile raggiungere
mi dimostrava che
non esistono sogni impossibili.
E mi ripetevo questa cosa
immaginando e sentendo che io avevo
in quel momento un solo desiderio,
una nuova idea:
essere a Rio, quattro anni dopo.
In quel momento incominciai
a tratteggiare un nuovo viaggio,
verso un'altra isola di utopia.
Pensai qualcosa del genere:
"Rio must be the place".
Io però a Rio non ci sono arrivato,
perché mi sono fermato un mese prima
delle qualificazioni per quelle olimpiadi,
rassegnando le mie dimissioni,
il 29 luglio del 2015,
in relazione a un fatto che non voglio
raccontare, perché non è importante.
È importante che avesse a che fare
col rispetto delle persone e dei valori,
cosa che a mio giudizio non erano,
non sono e non saranno mai negoziabili.
Non voglio giocare a fare l'eroe.
Se voi mi chiedeste: "Lo rifaresti?"
Io non vi saprei rispondere.
Quella scelta mi ha procurato
un dolore immenso, gigantesco.
Guardare alla televisione,
otto atleti che con me,
sui 12 presenti a Rio,
giocavano una finale olimpica,
è una sensazione che difficilmente
riuscirei a descrivere
quindi non ci provo neanche.
Voglio solo mettervi in guardia:
"the place" non esiste.
O almeno, non esiste per quanto voi
vi sforziate di definirne i dettagli,
non esiste come lo pensate voi.
L'isola che non c'è, appunto, non c'è.
"The place" è un viaggio.
La cosa bella è che ogni nostro viaggio
possa essere il più lungo possibile
pieno di ricchezze, di persone
da incontrare nel cammino, sulla strada,
pieno di posti dove farsi contaminare.
Proprio come succede nel viaggio
più famoso della storia della letteratura,
quello di Ulisse.
C'è, nel libro quinto dell'Odissea,
un momento in cui Ulisse
è sull'isola della Ninfa Calipso,
la donna più bella del mondo
che gli ha promesso l'immortalità,
se lui resterà lì con lei.
Ora, ditemi voi.
La donna più bella del mondo
e l'immortalità
sono due poste in palio
abbastanza significative,
eppure, Calipso trova Ulisse
seduto sulla spiaggia
che guarda il mare
con gli occhi rigati di lacrime
per questo desiderio, per la nostalgia
di ritornare alla sua isola.
Il desiderio e la nostalgia
sono un motore dalla forza inesauribile.
Siate consapevoli
che ci sarà sempre un luogo
verso il quale desideriamo ritornare.
Ma che ogni volta che ci arriveremo
ce ne sarà un altro
di cui sentiremo la mancanza.
C'è una poesia che racconta
di quel viaggio straordinario,
che è anche una meravigliosa e struggente
metafora sul senso della vita.
L'ha scritta Costantino Kavafis
nel 1911 e s'intitola "Itaca".
(Musica)
"Quando ti metterai in viaggio per Itaca
devi augurarti che la strada sia lunga,
fertile in avventure e in esperienze.
I Lestrigoni e i Ciclopi
o la furia di Nettuno non temere,
non sarà questo il genere di incontri
se il pensiero resta alto
e un sentimento fermo
guida il tuo spirito e il tuo corpo.
In Ciclopi e Lestrigoni, no certo,
né nell'irato Nettuno incapperai
se non li porti dentro
se l'anima non te li mette contro.
Devi augurarti che la strada sia lunga.
Che i mattini d'estate siano tanti
quando nei porti,
finalmente e con che gioia
toccherai terra tu, per la prima volta.
Negli empori fenici indugia e acquista
madreperle, coralli, ebano e ambre
tutta merce fina, anche profumi
penetranti d'ogni sorta;
più profumi inebrianti che puoi,
va in molte città egizie,
Impara una quantità di cose dai dotti.
Sempre devi avere in mente Itaca,
raggiungerla sia il tuo pensiero costante.
Tuttavia, non affrettare il viaggio;
fa che duri a lungo, per anni,
e che da vecchio
metta piede sull'isola, tu,
ricco dei tesori accumulati per strada,
senza aspettarti ricchezze da Itaca.
Itaca ti ha dato il bel viaggio, senza lei
mai ti saresti messo sulla strada.
Che cos'altro ti aspetti?
E se la trovi povera,
non per questo Itaca ti avrà deluso.
Fatto ormai savio,
con tutta la tua esperienza addosso
già tu avrai capito
che cosa un'Itaca vuole significare".
Qualunque sia la vostra Itaca,
buon viaggio!
Grazie
Applausi